[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundola
Gause und Marietta slomk guten Abend
wird bundesinnenministerin Nancy fer mit
Dreck beworfen wie sie heute im
Bundestag klagte oder hat sie etwas zu
verbergen und missachtet das Parlament
dass es dazu in Berlin gerade so hoch
hergeht dürfte auch mit dem häsischen
Wahlkampf Zusammenhängen fer tritt
bekanntlich als Spitzenkandidatin an und
da ist es nicht verwunderlich dass die
Konkurrenz so kurz vor der Wahl eine
offene Flanke nicht links liegen lässt
fers Problem ist dass der von ihr
geschasste Ex-Präsident des Bundesamtes
für cybersicherheit kürzlich Klage auf
Schadenersatz eingereicht hat und so
wird sie jetzt von einer alten
Geschichte wieder eingeholt die Frage
ist ob wegducken dabei die beste
Strategie ist Klaus brotbeck berichtet
aus
Berlin nun also doch über Tage schon
schweigt die Ministerin heute aber muss
sie reden Haushaltsdebatte im Bundestag
es geht um den et ihres Hauses ein
Pflichttermin den Nany Feser nutzt zum
Gegenangriff ich verstehe ja dass an den
kommenden
wocheneserden mit
ich kann ihn aber sagen liebe Union ich
mache meine Arbeit und anders als Ihnen
meine Damen und heren von der Union ist
mir die
cybersicherheit wichtig in diesem
Land denn ich habe das BSI angesichts
der aktuellen Bedrohung gestärkt und das
werde ich auch weitertun dafür war eine
Neuaufstellung an der Spitze notwendig
schönb verlor den Präsidentenposten
nachem eine Satiresendung im ZDF über
seine Nähe zu einem Verein mit
Beziehungen nach Russland berichtet
hatte noch am Morgen war fese zu einer
Sondersitzung des Innenausschusses
gebeten aber nicht erschienen bereits
zum zweiten Mal in dieser Woche die
Union empört feuert aus allen Rohren wir
haben inzwischen dreimal sie gebeten zu
den gravierenden Vorwürfen die im Raum
stehen Aufklärung zu sorgen und um Rede
und Antwort gebeten diese Möglichkeit
haben sie dreimal ausgeschlagen das
hätten wir auch heute früh um 730 Uhr
abhandeln können aber Frau fer war noch
nicht wach steht ein ernster Verdacht im
Raum nämlich die Instrumentalisierung
des Verfassungsschutzes um im Nachhinein
das ist der Verdacht ich sage das der
Verdacht um im Nachhinein eine falsche
Entscheidung von ihnen zu rechtfertigen
der Verdacht genährt durch einen
internen Vermerk aus dem
Bundesinnenministerium nach einem
Gespräch mit der Ministerin zu schönburm
hält ein hoher beamt fest sie war
sichtlich unzufrieden sie fand die Dinge
die wir ihr zugeliefert haben zu dünn
wir sollten nochmals das Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz abfragen und alle
Geheimunterlagen
zusammentragen fers Erklärung die
Abfrage sei nötig geworden weil
Schönbohm um ein Disziplinarverfahren
gegen sich selbst gebeten hatte diese
Prüfung meines Ministeriums war
gründlich und das musste sie auch sein
und um auch das jetzt ohne jeden Zweifel
klar zu sagen dabei sind keine
nachrichtendienstlichen Maßnahmen gegen
Herrn Schönbohm eingesetzt worden diese
Behauptung ist völliger Unsinn meine
Damen und Herren immer wieder geht es
auch um Hessen gut vier Wochen bis zur
Wahl entsprechend aggressiv gehen CDU
und SPD einander an sie haben das BMI zu
einer Wahlkampfzentrale ausgebaut und
das ist wirklich schlimm und schadet
unserer Sicherheit im Land bleiben sie
bei den Fakten und überlassen Sie es
doch der CDU in Hessen Wahlkampf zu
führen das müssen Sie nicht machen die
Affäre und ihr Umgang damit bleiben für
fäer vermutlich riskant in Hessen wie in
Berlin lar kasselucci ist uns
zugeschaltet der amtierende Vorsitzende
des Innenausschusses und von der SPD
guten Abend Herr kastelucci ja schönen
guten Abend Frau slamka Frau fer ist
ihre Parteifreundin also damit sind die
Fronten im Prinzip klar aber als
Parlamentarier ist ist das schön wenn
man jemanden eine Ministerin zu einem
Ausschuss einlädt und die kommt nicht
und die kommt gleich zweimal nicht ja
ich bin Vorsitzender dieses Ausschusses
und deswegen führe ich den auch
unparteiisch und die
parteimitgliedschaften dürfen da keine
Rolle spielen für uns als Parlamentarier
ist wesentlich dass die Fragen der
Parlamentarier beantwortet werden und
das ist vollumfänglich passiert und ich
muss als Vorsitzender auch über die
Geschäftsordnung wachen die
Geschäftsordnung gibt den Abgeordneten
ein starkes recht nämlich dass solche
Sitzungen beantragt werden können auch
von Minderheiten aber es gibt kein
zitationsrecht von Minderheiten das
heißt es kann nicht entschieden werden
von demjenigen der Antrag stellt wer
kommt und so ist Frau fäer ganz
herkömmlich von einer parlamentarischen
Staatssekretärin vertreten worden gut
jetzt wissen wir auch eine
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin ist
keine Staatssekretärin ne das ist also
jetzt auch noch nicht mal die
Leitungsebene des Ministeriums die sie
dort geschickt hat aber es geht ja um
eine politische Dimension das ist ja
jetzt keine reine
geschäftsordnungsveranstaltung also
einmal hatte sie ein Arzttermin und und
heute konnte sie morgens nicht weil sie
nachmittags eine Rede im Bundestag
halten will wer soll das denn glauben
also es geht nicht um die Gründe sondern
es geht einfach um eine freie
Entscheidung der Bundesregierung wer in
die Ausschüsse entsandt wird die
parlamentarischen Staatssekretärinnen
und Staatssekretäre sind die Vertreter
und die VertreterInnen der Minister und
damit die höchstrangigen die genau auch
dafür zuständig sind Frau Slomka der
Union geht es hier ja nicht um
Aufklärung in der Sache sondern es geht
um Wahlkampf und das erkennt man daran
dass immer wieder auch die gleichen
Sachen behauptet werden auch wenn sie im
Ausschuss bereits widerlegt worden sind
und da muss man auch an solches Spiel
nicht mitspielen als Ministerin also
ganz unparteiisch klingen sie da dann
jetzt aber
nicht also ich war im Innenausschuss in
beiden Sitzungen ich habe so etwas
übrigens noch nicht erlebt dass man in
einer Woche zwei solche Sitzungen
anberaumt dass die gesamte Korrespondenz
vorher an die Medien gegeben wird und
dass Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus der
Sitzung herausgehen und Dinge behaupten
die dem widersprechen was ihnen
vorgetragen wurde also das sind schon
Grenzen des Anstands und des
demokratischen Miteinanders verletzt
worden na ja also in Wahlkämpfen dass da
mit harten Bandagen rangegangen wird ist
ja klar aber dann könnte auch eine
veritable Ministerin die auch für law
und order und kräftig zupacken steht
sich dahinstellen und das Feuer selbst
austreten wenn da keins ist die
Ministerin hat ja heute im Parlament
auch etwas zu dem Vorgang gesagt noch
mal alle Fakten sind auf dem Tisch der
Zentrale Vorwurf ist ja dass es
nachrichtendienstliche Ermittlung im
Auftrag auch der Ministerin gegeben
hätte äh das ist nicht der Fall das hat
es nicht gegeben und hier werden
weiterhin Zweifel gestreut auch an der
Verfassungsmäßigkeit also der der Arbeit
unserer verfassungsbehörden des
Verfassungsschutzes und wer sich heute
besonders gefreut hat das war die AFD
Fraktion die ja als Verdachtsfall äh vom
äh Verfassungsschutz auch beobachtet
wird und die sich nun freut dass sich
auch die CDU angeschlossen hat
Zweifel an deren Arbeit zu sehen das ist
ein sehr unheilige Allianz die da
geschlossen wurde na gut aber man wird
jetzt nicht aufhören eine Ministerin
kritisch zu beugen nur weil das der AFD
dann vielleicht irgendwie gefallen
könnte es gibt ja nur mal diesen
Aktenvermerk in dem wenn man ihn richtig
liest vielleicht verstehe ich ihn ja
auch falsch helfen sie mir den Eindruck
gewinnen könnte die Ministerin hat da
etwas sagen wir mal auf dem sehr kleinen
Dienstweg bestellt und sich zukommen
lassen war das dann dann geschickt das
Gegenteil ist richtig es hilft auch
wirklich nichts vermerärke die von
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern in den
Ministerien
erstellt werden zu nehmen und dann
darüber zu spekulieren was damit gemeint
sein kann es ging darum dass Herr ähm
schönburm selbst beantragt hatte dass
die Vorwürfe gegen ihn geklärt werden
seitens des Ministeriums und in diesem
Zusammenhang äh sind Erkundigung
eingehob worden diese sind in einer
Kurzfassung der Ministerin vorgelegt
worden als ein eine Zusammenfassung und
die Ministerin hat dann darüber gebeten
dass man ihr direkt wahrscheinlich auf
den Schreibtisch auch die Langfassung
gibt damit sie sich über diesen
Sachverhalt der ja auch ein schwieriger
Sachverhalt war und wir befinden uns in
einem Angriffskrieg der Russlands auf
die Ukraine mit auch
Cyberangriffen auf Deutschland wo wir
uns wirklich nicht erlauben konnten dass
es einen Vertrauensverlust gerade in
diesem Bereich gibt da hat sich die
Ministerin selbst darum gekümmert und
das ist ein sehr sorgfältiges Vorgehen
gewesen Herr schönbum klagt ja weil er
sich da zu unrecht behandelt fühlt und
er sagt auch dass er bis heute
eigentlich gar nicht so genau Büsse
warum man ihm das Vertrauen entzogen hat
können Sie ihm da auf die Sprünge helfen
ja se er soll sich die Nachrichtenlage
der damaligen Zeit noch mal mal
anschauen es ist schon in der
Öffentlichkeit eine starke Resonanz
gewesen auf eine Sendung des ztf die
bmerendung ja also die ich auch nicht
gut fand und wir alle können Opfer won
falsch Anschuldigungen werden und das
ist auf jeden Fall etwas was nicht schön
ist das ist klar Moment aber sie sagen
Sie jetzt das sein falschanschuldigungen
gewesen in dem Bericht das sind doch
zwei verschiedene Schuhe kritischer
Bericht an dem die Redaktion übrigens
auch nichts zurückweist auf der einen
Seite und dienstrechtliche Verfehlung
die eine Ministerin zu einer Entlassung
bewegen keine Frage jetzt ging es ja
darum dass er nicht weiß warum in
Vertrauensverlust eingetreten sein
könnte und es ist damals in der
Öffentlichkeit einfach einen Eindruck
entstanden der sich der auch darauf
hinweist dass
eben ein Vertrauen in die Amtsführung
des Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der
Informationstechnik nicht mehr gegeben
ist und das konnten wir uns in dieser
Situation oder das sagt die Ministerin
in dieser Situation nicht erlauben dass
man da das Vertrauen nicht hat und es
ist dann ein Vorgang den ich als
Abgeordneter des Deutschen Bundestages
und auch Mitglied des Innenausschusses
mehrfach mitbekommen habe dass der
Präsident des Amtes für
Bevölkerungsschutz versetzt worden ist
dass die äh Präsidentin des Bundesamtes
für Migration und Flüchtlinge versetzt
worden ist äh einfach weil die damaligen
Minister der CDU gesagt haben ihnen
fehlt das Vertrauen in die Amtsführung
oder eine öffentliche Debatte die sich
um diese Personen oder um diese Ämter
entsponnen hat führt dazu dass es ein
Vertrauensverlust in die Amtsführung
geben könnte und das ist von Schaden und
dann
muss man ja sagen dass Herr schönburm
eine gleichwertige Funktion bei gleicher
Bezahlung auch jetzt erreicht hat und
das ist ja ein anständiger Umgang mit
dieser Sache na ja also er hat hatte
früher 1700 Mitarbeiter jetzt hat er 55
aber gut also das ist dann jetzt quasi
vielleicht auch nicht unser Hauptproblem
wie glücklich er damit ist meine hat
dann weniger Arbeit und das gleiche Geld
oder welche welche Frage verbinden Sie
jetzt mit der Anzahl der Mitarbeiter na
ja er fühlt sich natürlich in seinem
Ansehen massiv geschädigt und deshalb
klagt er ja auch deshalb ist er ja auch
so sauer zu klagen ist auch das gute
Recht in diesem Land und das soll dann
von den Gerichten auch geklärt werden
sagt der Vorsitzende des
Innenausschusses Herr kastelucci danke
für das Gespräch danke
Ihnen das Interview haben wir aus
Termingründen am früheren Abend geführt
langweilig ist es im deutschen
Parlamentsbetrieb jedenfalls gerade
nicht auch in Bayern ist Dampf im Kessel
mit parteipolitisch umgekehrten
Vorzeichen auch das vor dem Hintergrund
eines Wahlkampfs die Opposition hatte
Markus Söder und Hubert eiwanger heute
zu einer Sondersitzung geladen und
immerhin beide erschienen auch höchst
persönlich was nicht heißt dass sie
Fragen beantworteten beantwort
Simon Fanzelt hat das in München
verfolgt wie klingt für sie eine
ehrliche
Entschuldigung wie sieht Treue
aus wie bedauern sehr geehte
Ministerpräsident Söder fühlen sie sich
wohl mit ihrer Entscheidung in der
kauser
eiwanger auch wenn Söder und eiwanger
heute nichts sagen ihre Minen sprechen
und sie erzählen eine ganze Menge
fast regungslos sitzt der Minister da
als wäre er wieder der Schuljunge von
damals wer Vorwürfe des
Rechtsextremismus und des Antisemitismus
behandelt als ginge es dabei um eine
Fensterscheibe die man mal als Pub
eingeschossen hat der zeigt damit eben
einen Mangel an Sensibilität für die
Themen cho und die anderen Verbrechen
des Nationalsozialismus und er muss sich
Kritik daran auch gefallen lassen sie
kennen offenbar keine roten
sie wiegeln Menschen auf um daraus
politischen Profit zu schlagen und das
ist für mich ein klares Kennzeichen für
Rechtspopulismus es ist der Versuch die
flugblatffäre parlamentarisch
aufzuarbeiten heute im Bayerischen
Landtag während die Opposition viele
offene Fragen sieht sehen die
Regierungsparteien einen gelungenen
Umgang mit der Krise Söder und eiwanger
lassen sich loben von ihren
Leuten innerhalb einer Woche diese
Aufklärung zu liefern ist bei den
Sachverhalt sehr gut meine Damen und
Herren und es Erft Mut Fehler
einzugestehen und diesen Mut hat Hubert
eiwanger bewiesen unser
Ministerpräsident hat nicht taktiert
sondern er hat tatsächlich den Takt der
Aufklärung
vorgegeben er hat und war stets Herr des
Verfahrens während Söder schweigt sucht
die CSU erkennbar nach ihrer eigenen
Haltung sie muss die Entscheidung für
eiwanger gut finden und sich
gleichzeitig von eiwanger
distanzieren es sind Vorwürfe die das
Ansehen Bayerns schädigen und auch die
Glaubwürdigkeit des stellvertretenden
Ministerpräsidenten sehr belasten
aufrecht mutig und direkt heraus sein
muss man nicht nur im Bierzelt wo
vielleicht die Leute jubeln dennoch
stimmt die CSU heute gegen eiwangers
Entlassung aus dem Kabinett und erklärt
die Debatte für beendet doch es bleiben
Fragen etwa die was es bedeutet wenn das
flammenste pldoyier für eiwanger heute
von der AFD kommt ich halte es für
völlig unerhört dass gerade die
angeblich so toleranten Grünen und die
SPD sich damit nicht zufrieden geben
wollen und einem Menschen nicht
zugestehen wollen dass er sich in 35
Jahren vielleicht weiterentwickelt hat
auch mal vielleicht Fehler im Leben
gemacht hat aber dass er jetzt eben auch
ein anderer Mensch ist eiwanger geht so
wortlos wie er kam es ist kaum zu
erwarten dass sein Schweigen allzu lange
andauern
wird und die Nachrichten beginnen jetzt
mit dem Blick in die Hochwassergebiete
in Griechenland gundela dort ist die
Lage weiterhin kritisch zwar regnet es
seit den Abendstunden weniger aber nach
wie vor sind viele Dörfer fast völlig
von der Außenwelt
abgeschnitten auch die Hafenstadt wollos
die wichtigste Autobahn zwischen Athen
und Thessaloniki ist über 200 km
gesperrt das Militär ist im Einsatz um
zu helfen offenbar haben digitale
Warnsysteme funktioniert in der gesamten
unwetterregion also auch in Bulgarien
und der Türkei kamen aber mindestens 18
Menschen in den Fluten ums Leben unklar
ist wie viele vermisst
werden NATO Generalsekretär Stoltenberg
sieht Fortschritte bei der ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive im Kampf gegen Russland
die Gefechte seinen schwierig und sehr
heftig sagte er im EU-Parlament doch die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte zielten
Geländegewinne von etwa 100 m pro Tag
usaußenminister blinken hat in der
Ukraine die Widerstandskraft der
Menschen in den von Russland
attackierten Regionen gewürdigt er
besuchte Militäreinheiten die von den
USA ausgerustet
wurden in der Haushaltsdebatte des
Bundestages hat Wirtschaftsminister
habbeck trotz der Konjunkturflaute davor
gewarnt den Standort Deutschland
schlechts zu reden die Probleme hingen
zum Teil mit der geopolitischen
Situation zusammen oder sein Haus
gemacht Justizminister Buschmann
beschrieb die Bemühungen zum Abbau der
Bürokratie in Deutschland das sei eine
Herkules Aufgabe für die im
Gesundheitsbereich überfällige
digitalreform warb Minister Lauterbach
und kritisierte einen Reformstau seit
Jahren der Münchner Hauptbahnhof war
heute weitgehend lahm gelegt bei
Bauarbeiten in in der Region war eine
Oberleitung beschädigt worden dadurch
konnte der Münchner Hauptbahnhof nicht
mehr angefahren werden im Bahnhof waren
viele Reisende gestrandet erst Stunden
später konnten einzelne Fernzüge München
wieder anfahren laut deutscher Bahn wird
die Störung frühestens in den
Nachtstunden ganz behoben
sein die deutschen Ministerpräsidenten
und Präsidentinnen waren heute gemeinsam
in Brüssel zu einem Treffen mit der
EU-Kommission da ging es unter anderem
um die Asylpolitik man sei
zuversichtlich dass es bis Ende des
Jahres einen Kompromiss geben werde hieß
es danach aber selbst wenn wird das die
aktuellen Probleme so bald nicht lösen
nach der flüchtlingskrise 2015 hatte man
ja landaufland abgesagt dass ich ein
solches Chaos nicht wiederholen dürfe
man müsse besser vorbereitet sein nur
sind die Zustände in vielen Kommunen
jetzt schon wieder so dass man nicht den
Eindruck hat dass das gelungen ist die
asylbewerberzah sind seit Jahresbeginn
stark gestiegen und es entstehen
Notlösungen bei denen vorhersehbar ist
dass das nicht gut geht torbode mit
einem Beispiel aus Mülheim an der
Ruhe mülheimrad helle Neubauten alles
wirkt sehr akkurat mittendrin steht hier
ein alter Bürokomplex der jahrelang
nicht genutzt wurde seit Juni ist das
Gebäude eine zentrale
unterbringungseinrichtung für
Flüchtlinge des Landes NRW kurz
zue Menschen können hier untergebracht
werden zu viele so sehen es nicht alle
aber einige Anwohner so wie Hermann
knöhner und nein es stört nicht
grundsätzlich dass jetzt Flüchtlinge
seine Nachbarn sind mE Gefühl sagt mir
das also da ich will jetzt nicht gegen
Zahlen sprechen aber in solch einem
Bereich 650 Menschen unterzubringen für
mich uner da gibt's keine Kinder
Spielplätze gar nichts Natja K ist
Lokalpolitikerin sie hört sich die
Sorgen und Beschwerden der Anwohnerin
und Anwohner an und kann diese auch hier
und da verstehen ihr Eindruck das Land
hat hier in mülheimrad grobe
Planungsfehler gemacht ich finde so eine
große landesunterkunft kann nicht in dem
Stadtteil platziert werden wo es
überhaupt keine Infrastruktur gibt die
Menschen sind keine Gefangenen die gehen
natürlich raus die wollen auch spazieren
gehen was erleben was sehen das ist hier
oben nicht möglich es gibt kein
Lebensmittelgeschäft es gibt hier
einfach gar nichts doch die
Landesregierung hat derzeit wohl gar
keinen Spielraum auf steigende
Flüchtlingszahlen mit igneten Immobilien
zu reagieren sie hat Schwierigkeiten
überhaupt Immobilien zu finden seit
Kriegsbeginn in der Ukraine sollten
allein in NRW rund 34 000 Plätze für
Flüchtlinge geschaffen werden das Ziel
wurde nicht erreicht stattdessen werden
Flüchtlinge um Platz zu schaffen jetzt
oft kurzfristig auf die Kommunen
verteilt doch auch deren Kapazitäten
sind endlich die Kommunen sind natürlich
mehr als am Anschlag man kann schon
wirklich sagen dass es eine dramatische
Situation ist weil sich das Ende der äh
Menschen die kommen nicht abzeichnet und
insofern ist es natürlich so dass jetzt
viele dazu übergehen müssen dann auch
wieder tenhallen vorzubereiten weil der
der Zuzug so groß ist dass man das
ansonsten nicht wird abarbeiten können
die Landesregierung wiederum zeigt mit
dem Finger nach Berlin dort würden die
Fehler in der Migrationspolitik gemacht
die die Länder und Kommunen ausbaden
müssten das ist schwierig der Bund muss
seiner Steuerungsfunktion an der Stelle
mehr gerecht werden auch bei der Frage
wie eigentlich legale Migrationsprozesse
gesteuert werden sollen wie aber auch
die Frage von Rückführung besser
gesteuert werden sollen das ist eine
Frage beispielsweise an
migrationsabkommen noch gibt es viel
Akzeptanz für die geflüchteten auch hier
in mülheimrat der Unmut richtet sich
nicht gegen die Menschen er richtet sich
gegen die Planungsfehler in der Politik
die sollte reagieren damit die Stimmung
nicht
kippt so wie es bisher läuft wird die
Asylpolitik jedenfalls auch jenen nicht
gerecht die an erkannte Fluchtgründe
haben etwa weil sie aus einem Krieg
fliehen die Europäer werden auf diesen
insgesamten Migrationsdruck Antworten
finden müssen und dabei aber
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und Menschenrechte
waren unter dieser Headline hat die
deutsche Bundespolizei auch Schulungen
mit Grenzschützern in Saudi-Arabien
durchgeführt auch an Saudi-Arabiens
Grenzen kommen viele flüchtende an aus
Äthiopien und dem Jemen beides Länder
mit kriegerischen Konflikten die
deutsche ausbildungsmissionen sollten
auch dazu dienen menschenrechtskonformes
Verhalten zu fördern wie es hieß umso
verstörender ist es was
Menschenrechtsorganisationen aus dem
Grenzgebiet
berichten ihre Reise in der Hoffnung auf
ein besseres Leben in Saudi-Arabien
dauert Wochen zetaus Äthiopier sind
jährlich auf diesem Weg unterwegs doch
für viele endet dieser Traum
hier said hat Granatsplitter abbekommen
sa hat mehrere Kugeln in beiden Beinen
wcha hat Schussverletzungen in Arm und
Bein es waren bewaffnete saudische
Soldaten sie schossen mit Kugeln auf
uns seit vier Tagen liegt Sahib in
diesem Krankenhaus in der Nähe der
jemenitisch saudischen Grenze mindestens
20 Patienten seinen es monatlich die
hier mit schwersten Verletzungen
behandelt würden bestätigt der
Oberarzt zeigen die Menschen wurden
angegriffen ohne Abstand es sind direkte
Schüsse mit leichten und schweren Waffen
die saudischjemenitische Grenze hier
soll es seit Jahren systematisch zu
schweren Menschenrechtsverletzungen
durch saudische Grenzer kommen die
saudische Regierung aber dementiert das
sie sagen es seinen militante Gruppen im
Grenzgebiet die auf die eäthiopier
schießen würden eine Lüge behauptet
rabiesi er habe bis Anfang des Jahres
für den saudischen Geheimdienst
gearbeitet sei auch an der Grenze im
Einsatz gewesen dort gelte ein
spezieller
Befehl im Jahr 2020 kam ein
Tötungsbefehl von Prinz Mohammed bin
Salman persönlich der Befehl besagt
jeden Menschen zu töten der in die Nähe
der saudischen Grenze kommt dieser
Befehl differenziert nicht zwischen
Männern Frauen und Kindern jede Person
in der Nähe der Grenze wird als
Terrorist angesehen und muss sofort
neutralisiert
werden
im ZDF Interview betont er auch die
Mitschuld der deutschen Regierung denn
deutsche Bundespolizisten bilden
mitunterbrechungen seit 2009 die
saudischen Grenze
aus ich hoffe die deutsche Regierung
stoppt das Training nun für immer denn
die saudische Regierung tötet bis heute
äthiopische Migranten an der Grenze
überprüfen können wir nicht was er sagt
die Bundesregierung fordert Aufklärung
unterdessen auf diesem jemenitischen
Friedhof unweit der saudischen Grenze
wir finden eine Grabstelle für
äthiopische Migranten datiert auf Ende
August
2023 auf Nachfrage erzählt man uns man
erwarte in diesen Tagen neue tote
weitere Männer Frauen und Kinder aus
Äthiopien mit dem Treffen der deutschen
Ministerpräsidenten in Brüssel geht es
bei dir jetzt noch mal weiter Gundula da
ging es nämlich heute nicht nur um
Asylpolitik mit einer Brüssel Erklärung
fordern die Ministerpräsidenten der
Länder nach ihren Beratungen mit der
EU-Kommission staatliche Unterstützung
für energieintensive Unternehmen es gehe
um die Sicherung von
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und Arbeitsplätzen
etwa der Stahl und Chemieindustrie drohe
sehr großer Schaden die EU-Kommission
will die Pläne erst prüfen sobald die
Bundesregierung eine klare Linie
habe denn während die Grünen und Teile
der SPD die staatliche Subventionierung
befürworten Lehnen der Bundeskanzler und
die FDP einen
industriestrompreis ab zu teuer und
unnötig auch in der Wirtschaft ist das
Vorhaben umstritten Valerie hallle warum
ist z.B der Verband Maschinen und
Anlagenbau gegen diese Pläne ja der
Verband der Maschinenbauer spricht von
potenieller
Wettbewerbsverzerrung in der EU der
brückenstompreis konte karere den
europäischen ansatzprobleme gemeinsam
anzugehen ja dieses Argument zielt
darauf ab dass sich kleinere Länder eine
derartige Subvention möglicherweise
nicht leisten können und Nachteile für
ihre Industrie befürchten müssen auch
die Industrie und Handelskammer sieht
die Entlastung für die Industrie
übrigens kritisch viele Unternehmen
würden davon gar nicht profitieren
bräuchten aber dringend Unterstützung
und mit welchen Argumenten fordern
Befürworter den
industriestrompreis die
Ministerpräsidenten meinen dass eine
ganze Bandbreite von Industrien
profitieren würden Stahl Chemie Glas
Zement und einige andere ohne
Unterstützung sein sie im
internationalen Vergleich gar nicht
wettbewerbsfähig Ökonomen argumentieren
der brückenstompreis wäre ein Signal für
den Industriestandort Deutschland
Verbände warnen ja schon lange vor einer
Abwanderung von Betrieben in
kostengünstige Länder der Ball liegt
aber ohnehin im Feld der Bundesregierung
nur sie kann sich eine Subvention in
Brüssel genehmigen lassen doch dazu
müsste die Ampel erstmal eine gemeinsame
Linie finden vielen Dank wri für die
Einordnung er war mit 37 Jahren der
jüngste Regierungschef eines
Bundeslandes gestern ist Hamburgs
früherer erster Bürgermeister
Hans-ulrich Klose im Alter von 86 Jahren
gestorben von
1974 bis 81 leitete der SPD Politiker
die Geschicke im Hamburger Rathaus zwei
Jahre später wechselte Klose in den
Bundestag dem er 30 Jahre lang angehörte
D Jahre davon stand er der SPD Fraktion
vor Bundeskanzler Scholz würdigte den
erfahrenen außen und
Sicherheitspolitiker für seine klare
Haltung und seine klaren
Worte zum Sport Tennisprofi alexander
zwerev ist bei den US Open im
Viertelfinale ausgeschieden der
Olympiasieger aus Hamburg unterlag dem
Weltranglisten ersten Carlos alkaras aus
Spanien auch wegen einer Verletzung am
ob Schenkel klar in drei Sätzen zwerf
muss damit weiter auf seinen ersten
Grand Slam Titel
warten bei den Europameisterschaften im
Dressurreiten hat die deutsche ekip
erstmals seit 2015 den Titel verpasst
die Gastgebermannschaft von
Bundestrainerin theodoresku musste sich
im Grand Prix dem starken Team aus
Großbritannien geschlagen geben und
gewann Silber bronze ging an Dänemark
erst zum fünften Mal seit der
Teamwettkampf 1965 eingeführt wurde
stand Deutschland nicht ganz
oben kommen wir zu einer anderen
Preisverleihung nicht im Sport sondern
in der Wissenschaft der renommierte und
hochdotierte körperpreis für die
europäische Wissenschaft geht in diesem
Jahr an die KI Forscherin Cordelia
Schmied übergeben wird er ihr morgen und
damit wird sie aufgenommen in eine
Gruppe absoluter Spitzenforscher eine
ganze Reihe vor iger körberpreisträger
bekam später auch noch einen
Nobelpreis was es mit der Forschung
dieser deutschen
ausnahmeinformatikerin auf sich hat und
wie das unseren Alltag der Zukunft
berühren kann berichtet Christina
KZ nein eine gläserne Decke habe sie nie
gespürt erzählt Cordelia Schmied und
selbst wenn es Menschen gab die sie von
ihrem Weg in die Spitzenforschung
abbringen wollten so hat sie nicht
darauf gehört sie machte einfach weiter
bekam drei Kinder und ist jetzt eine der
renommiertesten Wissenschaftlerinnen im
Bereich künstliche Intelligenz alles
begann während ihres Studiums mit einem
Roboter und einem Würfel den Würfel
konnte der Roboter nicht erkennen oder
nicht immer erkennen und da habe ich mir
so gedacht das ist doch super
interessant wieso kann der das nicht von
Menschen ist ja total einfach ein Würfel
zu erkennen und die Eckpunkte auf dem
Würfel zu lokalisieren und das war so
der Moment wo ich gedacht habe so
interessant jetzt will ich jetzt einfach
das Problem
lösen heute gehören einfache Roboter
längst zu unserem Alltag so wie dieser
freundliche Helfer der gerade eine
Bestellung aufnehmen
möchte doch was er kann reicht Cordelia
Schmied nicht ihr Roboter Thiago hat
beinahe menschliche
Züge
er soll mehr verstehen differenzierter
Handeln ständig weiter lernen und dafür
so wie ein Kind direkt mit der Umgebung
in Kontakt kommen also wenn sie jetzt
nur sich vorstellen sie gucken nur ein
Film an können Sie natürlich aus dem
Film viel lernen aber dass sie wirklich
irgendwie lernen wie die Objekte
beschaffen sind die 3dstuktur brauchen
sie noch mal irgendwie Interaktion mit
der Umgebung und dann von meinem
persönlichen Hintergrund her finde ich
es natürlich spannend dass man irgendwie
Haushaltsroboter entwickelt und die
können dann praktisch ja gerade auch
Frau oder Familien helfen die
Haushaltsarbeiten zu
erleichtern eine schöne neue heile Welt
also voller Verbesserungen einen
Vergleich der KI mit der Atombombe will
Cordelia Schmied die auch für google
arbeitet nicht gelten lassen wo muss man
aufhören und ich merke mal die atombodde
hat nur negative Auswirkung während die
KI ja auch unheimlich viele positive
Auswirkungen
hat Roboter auf Augenhöhe vielleicht
sogar klüger und mächtiger als Menschen
eine solche Zukunftsvision fürchtet die
Informatikerin nicht sie hofft auf die
Hilfe von Robotern die aber Maschinen
bleiben Ziel ist auch nicht dass die
Maschine den so wier Mensch wird sondern
mit Ziel ist dass die Maschine praktisch
den Menschen hilft kreativer zu werden
besser seine Arbeit auszurichten oder z
die Kameras werden besser haben bessere
Funktionalitäten aber ersetzen jetzt
nicht den
Fotografen von menschlichen Fähigkeiten
ist Thiago weit entfernt sich frei zu
bewegen und einfach mal das Geschirr
wegzuräumen ist bislang noch eine zu
große Herausforderung für ihn das soll
auch manchen Menschen so gehen so viel
von uns gleich geht's bei malbr ilner
weiter sie hat unter anderem Christian
Lindner und Grünen Chefin Ricarda lang
zu Gast und um 0:30 Uhr meldet sich
nasan göckte mir mit unserem heute
journal Update morgen auf Wiedersehen
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das Tief Daniel wird in den
nächsten 24 Stunden weiter nach Süden
ziehen und damit lassen die kräftigen
Regenfälle in Griechenland nach das Hoch
Patrizia zieht nämlich auch weiter nach
Süden lenkt aber die Tiefs um sich herum
auch den ehemaligen Hurrican Frank der
bleibt einfach über dem Atlantik liegen
interessant sind aktuell bei uns die
Temperaturen häufig sind die höchsten
Temperaturen ja am oberrein zu erwarten
heute allerdings wurde es in Duisburg
besonders warm mit 32° und das lag an
einem kleinen Föhneffekt aus dem
Sauerland heute Nacht sinken die
Temperaturen an der Nordsee auf 18° bis
auf 9° in Bayern dazu ist es meist klar
erst im frühen Morgen entwickeln sich im
Süden vielleicht mal einige Nebelfelder
und morgen strahlt dann wieder die Sonne
bei südsüd Ostwind und es gibt Sommer
für alle also Sommertemperaturen
zwischen 26° am Alpenrand und 32°
westlich des Rheins und in Paris werden
morgen vielleicht sogar 35° erreicht
sonst sind es rund um das Mittelmeer 30°
am östlichen Mittelmeer um die 40°.
Kühler ist es im Norden und vor allen
Dingen auch im Nordwesten Europas mit 10
bis 20° und diese etwas tieferen
Temperaturen die kommen dann zur
Wochenmitte allmählich von Nordwesten
auch bei uns in Mitteleuropa an aber
noch nicht sofort das Wochenende und
auch der Montag werden noch sehr warm
bei 26 bis 33° und erst am Montag
verdichten sich die Wolken allmählich
von Westen guten Abend